THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: MARK STEYN IS AN
AUTHOR AND COLUMNIST, HE
JOINS US.
MARK, ARE YOU SURPRISED BY
THESE NUMBERS.
PEOPLE'S EXPERIENCE OF THE
TRANSFORMATIVE EFFECT OF
IMMIGRATION AND IT'S
LOGICAL, TOO.
THAT WHEN A FIRST WORLD
COUNTRY IMPORTS CONTINUOUSLY
A LARGE, UNSKILLED
POPULATION INTO ITS COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY, THAT IS -- THAT
AND THERE IS NO REASON WHY
THEY WOULD THEN HAVE ANY
OTHER RESPECT FOR OTHER
LAWS.
AND, TO BE HONEST, I FOUND
THAT LAST FIVE MINUTES
SURREAL WHERE, YOU KNOW,
YOUR GUEST'S MAIN CONCERN IS
CERTAIN ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
ARE GETTING CRIMES COMMITTED
POLICE.
THAT'S NOT WHAT THESE
STATISTICS SHOW.
THESE STATISTICS, WHICH FOR
POLITICAL CORRECTNESS
REASONS WE WERE PREVENTED
EFFECT IMPORTING A CRIMINAL
CLASS.
AND IT DOES NOT CHECK ANY
NOW, THE FEW OF US WHO HAVE
THE MISFORTUNE TO GO THROUGH
THE LEGAL IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM, I WENT TO SEE NEIL
AT HOMELAND SECURITY IN
MANCHESTER, NEW HAMPSHIRE A
COUPLE YEARS AGO AND HE
ASKED ME WHETHER I COMMITTED
ANY CRIMES AND I SAID I HAD
BEEN PULLED OVER BY A
TRAFFIC COP IN VERMONT FOR
PASSING A LITTLE OLD LADY AT
NEIL FROM HOMELAND SECURITY
IN MANCHESTER, NEW
HAMPSHIRE, WANTED TO SEE
PROOF THAT THE STATE OF
VERMONT HAD ACTUALLY
SO, WE HAVE A BIFURCATED
SYSTEM HERE IN WHICH LAW
ABIDING PEOPLE HAVE TO DOT
EVERY I AND CROSS EVERY T
AND EVERY SINGLE DAY WE
IMPORT DRUG GANGS, MONEY
LAUNDER ERRORS
LAUNDERERRRORS
LAUNDERERS,ORS
LAUNDERERS, DS
LAUNDERERS, DRUNK DRIVERS,
THE LOBBYIST GROUP YOUR
PREVIOUS GUEST REPRESENTED
SOMEHOW THINKS THIS IS IN
THE INTEREST OF THE UNITED
STATES.
IT'S NOT AT ALL.
>> Tucker: THE RECTOR OF MY
CHURCH SPENT BETTER PART OF
A YEAR WAITING FOR A VISA.
THEY DIDN'T WANT ANY MORE
SCOTTISH ANGLICANS IN THIS
NOT FOR PEOPLE COMING
ILLEGALLY.
THE KEY ARGUMENT HAS ALWAYS
ISN'T THAT THE ARGUMENT YOU
HEAR EVERY DAY?
THEY COMMIT FEWER CRIMES AND
WORK HARDER.
THEM.
THEY ARE FOR AMERICAN NATIVE
BORN.
WHAT'S THEIR ARGUMENT NOW?
>> WELL, NANCY PELOSI HAS
SAID THAT WE OUGHT TO THANK
THE PARENTS OF THE DREAMERS
BETTER THAN US.
IF YOU LISTEN TO PEOPLE LIKE
YOUR PREVIOUS GUEST, EVERY
SINGLE DREAMER IS A HIGH
SCHOOL VALUE PARTICULAR
VAHOOL VALUE PARTICULAR
VALEOL VALUE PARTICULAR
VALEDI VALUE PARTICULAR
VALEDICTALUE PARTICULAR
VALEDICTORUE PARTICULAR
VALEDICTORIA PARTICULAR
VALEDICTORIANPARTICULAR
VALEDICTORIAN WRTICULAR
VALEDICTORIAN WRAICULAR
VALEDICTORIAN WRAPPULAR
VALEDICTORIAN WRAPPINAR
VALEDICTORIAN WRAPPINGR
VALEDICTORIAN WRAPPING UP
STATES IS TO IMPORT MORE AND
MORE LOW SKILLED IMMIGRANTS
ILLEGALLY ACROSS THE RIO
GRANDE.
IMMIGRANTS THAN YOU ARE IN A
TOWN WHOSE POPULATION GOT
OFF THE MAYFLOWER.
AND THE FACT OF THE THAT'S
RIGHT IS THIS IS ABSOLUTELY
THE INVERLS OF THE TRUTH.
THE STATISTICS YOU CITED.
EVEN TAKING AS A WHOLE, 94%
OF THESE NONCITIZEN
CRIMINALS IN FEDERAL CUSTODY
90% OF INCARCERATION IS AT
NONCITIZEN CRIMINALS IN U.S.
FEDERAL PRISON ARE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
WHY DOES ANY COUNTRY NEED TO
IMPORT A CRIMINAL CLASS?
IF THAT IS ONE OF THE JOBS
THAT AMERICANS WILL DO?
AMERICANS ARE HAPPY TO
MURDER AND RAPE AND SELL
DRUGS TO EACH OTHER, YOU
DON'T NEED TO IMPORT OTHER
PEOPLE TO DO THAT.
>> Tucker: ONE JOB THAT
AMERICANS ARE LESS
INTERESTED IN IS VOTING
DEMOCRAT.
POINT OF THE WHOLE THING.
MARK STEYN, THANK YOU.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.